okay acceleration last lesson
we connected uh that's okay equations
and motion right equations of motion so
we said
you know x we call that displacement
we said if you differentiate once with
respect to time okay
you get x dot and that gives you
velocity
right so then if you differentiate again
we said we sort of just teased at the
idea that you'll get x double dot which
is acceleration
but
that leads to some problems okay um
particularly with the way we speak
so this is kind of the difference
between um yeah maths and the whole
theoretical the world we've invented
okay and um what the real world actually
behaves like and how we talk about it
okay so for instance when we
use the word acceleration right what do
we usually mean like if you come with a
synonym like a phrase
what does accelerate that's got it right
yeah what does accelerate mean
what a troll okay so physics man over
there
gives a definition to do with forces and
mass okay i think most of us will say
you're accelerating if you're going
faster
right um usually accelerate
means go faster higher
or increase in speed right increase in
speed
so for instance if i'm going 60 k's an
hour okay
and i'm level at 60k and i'm not um
changing that speed i'm not going any
faster than that i would say i'm not
accelerating
okay now what's the opposite of
accelerating
decelerating right decelerating
okay so what does decelerate mean it
means you're still going in the same
direction right
but you're going slower in other words
your uh speed is decreasing
okay now i want you to take this
language and have a think about
um joe's mandarin okay joe's mandarin
do you remember uh if you graph
displacement against
time okay it looks something like this
so how would you describe the movement
of the mandarin
in terms of these words right what's it
doing
from here to here how would you describe
it
maybe i should ask this how fast is it
going
uh up here like at the top it's not
moving right has no velocity right
over here it has some velocity whatever
it is okay
so you're going from some velocity to
none so what's it doing
we would say the mandarin is
decelerating
okay then it gets to this point and then
what
it starts to accelerate right until it
goes back to my hand
okay so we'd say decelerate
and excellent that's about normal
languages okay
but if you come back to um what
equations we have okay
now see if you can help me remember i
think we said that x was equal to
minus 3 on 49
t t
minus 14. something like that right it
doesn't really matter
okay now you can see right if we
differentiate this once to get to
velocity
okay uh what are you going to get well
you're going to have a i'm just going to
forget about the coefficients for a
second okay
you've got a t squared and a t okay so
you're going to get something like
2t minus 1 plus my sorry minus 7 plus
is that right yeah does that make sense
because this is negative and that's
positive okay
and there will be some some coefficient
out the front okay
then you differentiate again to get to x
double dot
right now without knowing any of the
numbers what kind of function is x
double dot going to be
it's going to be constant right in fact
you can see it's going to be
maybe two times it'd be like actually
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna ignore it
some constant number and it'll be
negative
okay now it might not be minus two it'll
be some different value
but it's still gonna be negative now
what does that mean okay
over here uh it's constant and it's
negative
constant and negative now this actually
makes sense because usually we associate
second derivative which is x double dot
with what geometric feature
think back to y11 this is concavity
right in other words
we're saying this it's always concave
down okay
but therefore you know when you talk
about accelerating and decelerating
um the language starts to break down
okay because when you look at this
versus this can you see that these
are to do with remember we gave them a
name when there's a quantity and it's
just a number
has nothing to do with direction do you
know what that was called
it was called a scalar right
but what we're dealing with displacement
and velocity acceleration
all of these equations they're not
scalar they are vector they include
direction
right okay so here's what you need to
have in like big red letters okay
don't never ever never ever never never
never never
never get it back together i'll never
write
never write decelerating okay please
never
don't don't do it okay here's why
decelerating right and the idea of
something you're
slowing down okay it's valuable but it
doesn't connect at all to the equations
that you're working with
okay here's what you should say what we
mean when we're like
going faster or those kinds of things
right a better way to talk that is
acceleration with regard to its sign
okay
so positive acceleration
and negative acceleration
okay now the positive and the negative
don't refer to whether you're getting
faster
or whether you're getting slower they
refer to which way the acceleration is
okay so here the acceleration is always
downward
and that corresponds to a force force
that we're all very familiar with we're
interacting with it right now namely
gravity okay it's downward and it's
constant
okay so this really should be you know
like minus 10
meters per second per second okay so
positive acceleration is up it might
slow you down
does that make sense positive
acceleration is up and will slow you
down
if you're coming downwards okay
and acceleration is going against the
way you're going does that make sense
so if i turn this graph upside down
okay i can say this in two ways it's
concave up
so that means it's accelerating upwards
okay but from here to here
i'm slowing down right even though i've
got positive acceleration
okay so the key i want to get into your
head is positive
and negative are about the direction of
the
force if you want to use physics
language or just say the direction of
the acceleration
okay now that's just the key
idea to get as a minor issue
because we're talking here about
displacement which is like say a
distance or a length
that might be meters you can talk about
velocity
right that's length over time so
therefore it might be saying
meters per second okay now because
meters per second and
per means division you often see that
written as meters
second minus one because when you raise
something to the power of minus one
you put it on the bottom okay in exactly
the same way
acceleration is this divided by time
again
right that's what differentiating does
again so this is either meters per
second
per second okay because it's about speed
per second
changing or you might see that as meters
per second to the minus two
they're all same and you can use any of
them when you're in your actual notation
okay